my old lady began as a play back in 2002
and played successfully all over the
world what was it that inspired you to
now say let's bring it to the big screen
the play was invited to the Moscow Art
Theater went into the repertory of the
Moscow Art Theater and I was there
watching the play being coerced the
Moscow Aarthi so I went and it was being
performed in a language I don't speak in
the slightest and the casting I missed
the 75 years that made the actress the
great actress that she must have been
but what I was seeing was somebody who
looked vaguely like Elvis presently at
the end of his life and I was really
daydreaming and I and I remembered that
I wrote I started to play as that kind
of Valentine's of France for because
I've had about 50 of my plays performed
there and translated and performed there
and and I was looking at the play and I
thought but France really it isn't in it
it's just people talking about it anyway
I started the daydream the movie eyes I
could see Kevin's character walking in
Paris and I and I said that just
combined with a simple fact that I was
about 73 years old maybe 74 and I knew I
was going to be and I wanted to do
something that would really scare me and
so I put the two things together and I
went to Rachel and I said according to
Rachel I told her she was going to
produce the movie I think I asked her
but anyway here we are
Rachel what were your recollections when
your dad said to you we're gonna make a
film well it's not the first project
that we talked about doing together but
my immediate attraction was I always
loved the play and I always loved our
family time in Paris that was something
that we my father was very close to a
number of major Parisian playwrights
Samuel Beckett Illinois Eugene and ESCO
and we would drop a few names just a few
so in the back of my mind I thought it
would be an opera
- ninny it was opportunistic to spend
time really honestly to spend time with
my father because to spend time with my
father means working with my father and
and also to get to work in France but to
do it together Gary when were you
brought onto the project I was sitting
on Martha's Vineyard last May and Israel
called me and said hey what are you
doing I said I'm on Martha's Vineyard
and he goes I'm making a movie and I
said fantastic you're he said I'm
directing it and my daughter rachel is
producing and I said fantastic now why
are you calling and he said well you
know we could use some help but maybe a
few bucks and I saw you just on Facebook
I saw that you just produced an
independent movie I said have Rachel
call me so Rachel and I spoke and I had
this idea that BBC films might be a
great partner for this movie and they
were you know so I had I had been
working with him on something else and
so gave them the script and told them
what it was about and they came back and
said how much do you need and it was one
of those great phone calls and the great
question in fact I asked for a number
and then when Israel met with them in in
London he goes we need more but it has
been a real pleasure to work with Israel
and Rachel and as Israel likes to call
me the fifth Beatle I feel like I'm an
adopted Horvitz at this point well I I
first read the script because some
quixotic French producer offered me this
the role of Mattias in the French
production in Paris because I foolishly
had done a couple of interviews for a
movie I was promoting in French and I
learned how to talk about myself in
French that's all I could do because
there's no and but the interviewers were
encouraged me anyway so they I said I
can't speak French that well I can't do
it but that's when I first read it in
English and then when this weird thing
happened where I bumped into Israel I
was at the café de Flore having coffee
with a friend downstairs because I was
there promoting a film that I had done
in French I mean I speak a little but
and I can act like someone who speaks
French I did anyway in a movie so uh I
was there promoting the movie the
producer of that movie was having lunch
with Israel upstairs at the café de
Flore where Sartre invented
existentialism and and I went up to use
the bathroom they it turns out we're
talking about who is who he wanted to
play Matthias and he said my name and
then I appeared at the top of the stairs
I thought they had sent me up I thought
it was a joke and then I thought but I
could have said Barack Obama how did
they know I was going to say Kevin Kline
and so he waved and I we and I went over
the table and they said then he said we
were just talking about you and how
perfect you'd be tea in this part and
when I get back to New York I'll send
you the script oh yeah right and I said
well please do a Laurita dive right away
and he thought yeah right but he did
send it and I did read it and the rest
is and then we just started working on
it and I had the privilege of watching
Israel over the period of four years and
a series of readings that he organized
down at his apartment with various
actors to watch it transformed from a
play to a film in that apartment resides
Dame Maggie Smith and I wonder if he
could talk about her involvement in this
film how did that come well Kevin came
Kevin came first and and and when we got
a script that we we all felt was slim
enough to and movie enough to give to
Maggie Rachel got the script to Maggie's
agent and miraculously she said yes and
I flew to Paris to have lunch with her
London yes of course that's where they
speak English and and I remember vividly
her saying to me I had several scripts I
I could have accepted but I took your
script would you like to know why and I
knew whatever she said was going to hurt
my feelings
but I was brought
to be a polite guyun and i said yes i
asked ya why didn't my why did you and
she said because i don't have to die at
the end of your movie darling
and then kevin topped it when I came
back in New York and he told me that he
was doing the movie because he thought
it might be his last chance to get the
girl I don't think it's his last year he
was since then and Kristin Scott Thomas
lived about 6 minutes walk from the set
so we know what she did the movie Kevin
can you talk about working with Maggie
Smith I mean no I don't think I should
she was well you can imagine no you
can't it was a treat it was a lesson it
was she the first thing that of course
amazed as any actor who's playing
opposite someone of this iconic stature
who you've grown up watching and
revering and she's an actress you know
she's just like us she's there she knows
her lines she knows what she's doing
and being English also I find in general
British actors don't like to talk about
subtext just do it you know let's get on
with it sort of just think that sort of
attitude you know stiff upper lip and so
it was not a lot of chant we just did it
and because of the schedule there was
not a lot of time for you know
rhapsodizing or trying idiotic
variations that were never going to be
using some really good to the understand
I've got some really good theater
stories she filled in a lot of blanks in
my you know I I once accused in a
company of English actors of studying
anecdotes in drama school because that's
all they have so many theatre stories
it's like they're famous for it I only
have one night just told it